Hannity and tonight we are broadcasting
live from Bedford New Hampshire it is
the night before the primary and at this
hour we are monitoring what is a huge
Unity rally in the granite state
featuring three former 2024 hopefuls uh
Senator Tim Scott V ramaswami and
Governor Doug bergham is there along
with the current GOP front runner Donald
J Trump we're going to take you there
live he should be taking the stage any
moment when the 40 fifth president steps
up to the podium now in the general
election President Trump now leads Biden
more than ever look at this morning
console poll 2024 tracking and meanwhile
in New Hampshire Trump is expected to
win big in tomorrow's primaries when you
look at the real clear politics average
look at this The Washington Post
16-point lead according to Emerson he's
leading by a whopping 27 points the
later uh the latest inside Advantage uh
that would be the Matt toy pole uh they
nailed it look at that that he's up by
22 or more uh that was
6237 the Boston Globe has him up by 19
the new fake news CNN poll even has them
up by 11 and last week it was seven that
same CNN poll found that the Santa
supporters are more likely to back
Donald Trump now that the Florida
governor has pulled out of this race and
while Governor D santz won't be the 2024
nominee let me just say one thing about
him his campaign he is without a doubt a
leader in our current conservative
movement he's an American first
conservative one of the most successful
governors in Florida's history and you
might recall in 2018 Governor DeSantis
won the State of Florida by around
30,000 votes four years later he won
re-election by more than 1.5 million why
because he did he did a great job as
governor for the people in the Free
State of Florida he's a fighter he
always puts America first he was
especially true uh we saw this during
the co
pandemic uh and despite hysteria from
the woke mob he withstood all those
attacks he was one of the first
governors in the country to reject
lockdowns he opened schools in August of
2020 and he defended freedom and the
free state of Florida is now well my new
home on top of everything but it is one
of the hottest destinations in the world
and growing at a very rapid rapid pace
and of course politics is a blood sport
during this primary Governor Des santis
was up against well someone that is
capable of defying all conventional
political gravity but Ronda santis is
only 45 years old his future incredibly
bright and Florida lucky to have him as
a governor and now we're down to a
two-person race between Donald Trump and
Nikki haly you do have to give Nikki
Haley credit she's the last Challenger
standing but she is in a pretty tough
spot as of tonight not only is she
losing according to the real clear
politics average by 18 but she's almost
down by 30 points in our home state of
South Carolina according to the latest
Emerson poll still the former Governor
Ambassador is picking up support from an
unlikely group of Voters Biden
supporters what's going on here take a
look you decided who you're going to
support on Tuesday yes I think I have I
think I'm a Nicki supporter are you open
to supporting Joe Biden I am I voted for
him in the last
election I love the Live Free or Die
State I love New Hampshire I love the
people new Hampshire I don't like their
voting system uh Independence Democrats
they call it an Open Primary they
register as Independence Democrats
sometimes do and then they can vote in
the Republican primary based on multip
multiple reports Haley has a ton of
support from Americans who will likely
vote for Biden regardless if Nikki Haley
won here in the New Hampshire primary I
don't like that system now still Nikki
Haley has an uphill battle in New
Hampshire and Trump is expected to win
if you believe the polls but the only
poll that really matters matters that
will be tomorrow's primary anything can
happen but if in fact Haley does lose
and lose by a pretty big margin she will
have an important decision to make and
that is does she want to go into her own
State and risk losing by a big margin in
a moment we'll take you live to that
Trump route hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else